the US military prepares for many
battles including ones that could extend
into space the Air Force considers space
to be a war fighting domain just like
air land and sea but space is getting
crowded and competitive with more
countries developing new technologies
the u.s. also tracks more than 500,000
pieces of debris or space junk that
complicate operations in orbit bianna
golodryga visited a base in Colorado to
see how the Air Force is defending
America thousands of miles above Earth
Deanna good morning good morning that
space junk by the way it's quite
dangerous traveling at 17,000 miles per
hour the u.s. used to be dominant in the
world of space but now not so much in
the last decade Russia and China have
caught up creating a three-way space
race and now as tensions with North
Korea escalate the US military is
preparing for a potential war above when
North Korea or any other country
launches missiles like these the airman
at Buckley Air Force Base in Colorado
are the first people in the world to
know about it they provide the US and
its allies with 24/7 surveillance of all
missile launches around the world is a
very demanding job it's very no-notice
kind of things up at 28 lieutenant Jon
Stryker is among the oldest on the team
like an old man not until just now
Stryker squadron routinely practices
exercises like this one who did you call
we call the next person in the chain who
puts together a sight picture for higher
headquarters and ultimately our
country's leadership it's a missile
warning detection satellite that chain
of command leads to 4-star General J
Raymond the military's top space
commander we're doing a lot to prepare
for a potential conflict that may extend
into space we do not want this war to
happen and one way to make sure that we
don't fight this war is to be prepared
to fight and win if were to happen and
we are 10 countries including North
Korea and Iran now have the ability to
launch a satellite into orbit
Russia and China are developing
technology that could blind or damaged
US satellites our job is to provide by
global I'm blinking eye to be able to
detect and warn against those threats
and be able to provide that to the
decision-makers and how confident are
you that that blinking eye will really
never blink it doesn't blink it's always
open that's partly because of these
giant golf ball-like structures that dot
the Aurora Colorado skyline inside each
of these weather resistant domes
sits a 60-foot satellite dish it scans
the planet for the most dangerous
weapons many people think that we have
missiles inside these ray domes you do
not have anything that dangerous this
close to Denver
they are simply satellite antennas meant
to pass mission data about 60 miles
south that Schriever Air Force Base in
Colorado Springs in this highly
restricted and unassuming room just
eight people keep watch over the global
positioning system or GPS copy
disconnects route the air force
developed GPS during Desert Storm to
help soldiers communicate
GPS helps the military fly aircraft and
drop bombs with greater accuracy so the
satellites are constantly emitting that
signal for you to be able to track where
you are
captain Brittany Morton says GPS has
been woven into virtually every aspect
of life on earth as it affects four
billion users worldwide
what kind of thing in this world you
know that affects everybody in that in
the globe financial transactions power
grids and farming equipment all rely on
precision timing from GPS and that makes
these satellites a prime target for our
adversaries is an attack on a satellite
an act of war I think it depends on the
context first of all let me state that
we do not want to get into a fight that
extent in there in the space we are all
about deterring that we would take it
seriously because satellites provide our
nation with great capability and great
advantage it be something that would be
very concerned about so what keeps you
up at night there's not a lot that keeps
me up at night there really isn't
I am extremely confident in the airmen
that I'm privileged elite or the envy of
the world so if nothing keeps you up at
night
what is it that's challenging you what's
challenging me is wanting to go fast we
have the world's best space capabilities
we want to run fast to make sure that
that's always the case so this is truly
the new battle for supremacy tomorrow
we'll take you to Cheyenne Mountain Air
Force Station known as America's
fortress the underground bunker is
designed to survive any nuclear or
missile attack and it could possibly
serve as the eyes and ears of the
president if the homeland were ever
attacked as well you know we talked
about the satellites North Korea just
last week said that it would like to
expand its satellite program they say
for economic reasons of course the
Western world believes that they want to
do it for their nuclear program to put
it in context they have two satellites
in space we have over 500 where sets go
yeah that's great thank you very much
Fiona